ce prix François Sagan ce ce prix unique
pour les livres était souhaité par les
éditeurs mais aussi par quelques auteurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est un
avantage pour les auteurs oui je pense
c'est un des moyens de un des moyens de
savoir ce que ce ce qu'on pouvait gagner
par exemple si on vous dit placard 50000
exemplaires vendu et qu'on sait quel est
le prix du livre on peut
calculer si on s'enoccupe on peut
calculer qu'on a gagné quoi en fait le
système précédent était surtout bon pour
pour les bestseller dont vous êtes
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu on savait
pas si on disait monsieuriteur j'ai
gagné temps puisque j'avais temps sur on
vous dit ah oui mais c'était pas le même
prix que ou quef ça dev extrêmement
compliquéo oui ça vous pensez que ça
peut assaainir un petit peu tout tout ce
milieu pour les auteurs c'est mux et je
crois pour C librairies les petites
librairies qui n'ont pas concurrencer
des les gros les gros centres c'est bien
ça vous êtes notre invité ce soir pour
votre nouveau roman la femme fardée
c'est un gros roman on va le voir paru
chez ramse en cette période de l'année
on pourrait penser que c'est un livre
pour l'été moi j'aurais plutôt tendance
à dire que c'est c'est un livre un livre
d'automne il y a une ambiance un petit
peu de fin de saison avec ce que ça
comporte de de nostalgie de de cruauté
de richesse aussi c'est c'est ça
l'ambiance de la femme fardée B Liv dire
si si on a envie de partir en vacances
on peut l'emmener en disant que ça va
coinciider AC les vacances et si on
regarde ses vacances on peut l'emmener
en pensant ça ça va vous rappelerété on
c'est un livre de croisière hein tout se
passe sur un sur un paquebo et cette
ambiance du bateau c'est une ambiance un
peu un peu feutré le bateau c'est un
endroit don on ne s'échaffe pas on est
obligé d'aller jusqu'à la fin du voyage
c'est c'est oui c'est ce qui explique
général que les gens qui partent en
bateau ensemble finissent toujours
toujours brouillé parce queon est on est
coincé on peut pas sauter la mer on peut
rester là de supporter les cel dit pour
un auteur cé assez commode parce que si
si on oublie un personnage on peut
toujours dire dans le chapitre suivant
il n'a pas bougé de sa cabine il avait
mal au cœur oui c'est un lieu clot on
peut bien nouer les intrigues oui on
peentirer comme ça qui est cette femme
fardée moi j'allais vous demander est-ce
que vous démasquez jamais vos
personnages finalement il y a pas de clé
j'ai je prends pas de clé je pas je suis
pas quelqu'un très observateur alors en
imaginant finalement je suis plus proche
de la vérité en imaginant qu' qu'en
copiant oui mais c'est tout un petit
microspos mais un petit univers qui qui
vit sur ce bateau je crois que tout tout
bateau comporte un espèce de de de côté
comme ça
mais ce côté impossibilité de sortir
impossibilité de presque obligation de
se connaître les uns et les autres
entraî et très vite ça pass en une
semaine on doit avoir une idée de
quelqu'un d'autre ça entraîne à des
relations plus rapides plus plus plus
enfin pour unuteur c'est assez idéal
parce qu'on d'aller loin et
vite je suppose qu'un auteur a de la
sympathie pour ces pour ces personnages
qu'est-ce qui vous avait donné envie de
créer celaord CIT l'idée de cette
croisière incroyable où on met les gens
sur un bateau puis le on les Bour on les
bour de MO un prix exorbitant on les
bour de de caviè par la bouche de
musique par les oreilles de parfum de
limosa par la de de mer par la vue enfin
ils sont obligés d'être d'être
parfaitement heureux de T les côtés son
côté ça ressemble un petit peu à cette
époque il faut toujours tout faire très
vite comme ça et être ça me paraiss une
idée extravagante alors j'ai mis des
gens dessus et puis beaucoup maient au
départ sympathique d'autres antipathique
mais au bout de 8 jours les gens
devinent plus ou moins forcément
sympathique on peut pas cohabiter avec
la moié des gens sur le prêter des côtés
un peu vulnérable ou un peu
attendrissant alors ce qui fait que les
méchants sont devenus Mo enins nombreux
et les sympathiques de plus en plus plus
en plus nombreux aussi merci franço